it's that struggle it's that  confrontation with what you're grappling  with that is like the stuff of life like  lean into it our instinct is to shun it  or avoid it or pretend it's not there  but the truth is there's this incredible  gift if you move towards it  we're here to grow we're here to learn  we're taught that our lives that the  lives best lived are the ones that are  strife-free the ones that are free of  trauma and tragedy but that's just not  the case in anybody I've met and  certainly the interesting people that  I've met so if you can tweak your lens  on it and perceive it through that kind  of perspective  perhaps it will energize you